roads and bridges broadband expansion
fixing potholes repairing rusting
bridges fixing train tracks
increasing internet access for everybody
it all sounds pretty reasonable right
any country should have all that
remember trump wanted to do
infrastructure and yet
pelosi impeachment never got it done
well tonight
i'm going to tell you what counts as
infrastructure
the republicans agreed to this without
even ever having read
a draft of the bill they put it was put
together mostly by the majority party's
committee staff
now in june a bipartisan group of
senators led by mitt romney thought it
was a good idea
to engage with president biden on this
thing called an infrastructure
bill that would cost hundreds of
billions of dollars now the deal
included biden's pledge and they were
all together in one room
that it would be a standalone in other
words it wouldn't be linked
with this 3.5 trillion or 4 trillion
spenderama that the democrats were
cooking up
to pass through this thing called
reconciliation which means you only need
a simple majority
of course biden is so out of it he
couldn't remember though
what he said to whom about the
negotiations
and so he ended up tipping the
democrat's hand
both of these measures to come to you in
tandem
did you receive any assurances that that
will happen
of course this made the republicans look
like charlie brown on their back with
pelosi as lucy
grinning holding the mr football
do you support then speaker pelosi's
stated plan to hold
the bipartisan deal in the house until
the senate also passes reconciliation do
you support that sequencing on her card
yes look the bipartisan bill from the
very beginning is understood there's
going to have to be the second part of
it
let's just sign the bipartisan no one
forget about the press
everyone knew there's always going to be
another bill that was going to be linked
well a few days later biden claimed he
misspoke
but we all know what he said about the
two bills really being one bill
is the truth in other words if you vote
for the infrastructure plan which needs
a filibuster-proof majority
you're effectively paving the way for
this
massive budget bill multi-trillion
dollar
extravaganza creating brand new
entitlement spending
and transforming much of american
society from top to bottom
oh and that bill as i said will only
need to pass
by a simple majority you get it but the
republicans had once again
looks like they had been played remember
pelosi she doesn't mess around
let me be really clear on this we will
not
take up a bill in the house
until the senate passes the bipartisan
bill
and an emphasis and a reconciliation
bill
there ain't going to be an
infrastructure bill
unless we have the reconciliation bill
passed
by the united states senate
gonna be one now again she plays
hardball
why republicans are waiting for a wiffle
ball game to start
she's not taking up infrastructure until
they get their gargantuan spending
package through a simple
majority vote simply put
by agreeing to this order of things the
romney group
gave up all of their leverage as
democrats are able to bypass them
entirely
on their way to a simple majority vote
on a 3.5
trillion dollar package that no one's
seen
now some of what we do know that will be
included
in this second bill universal pre-k
free meals for all students family
medical leave a pathway to citizenship
for the daca recipients
greener farming and expansion of
medicare and that's just the beginning
and today more than a month after the
romney group met with biden
the democrats finally released their
infrastructure bill
110 billion dollars roads bridges major
projects 66 billion for railways 65
billion for broadband but that's not all
there were more gems buried in the text
which most senators obviously won't have
the time to read
it's 2 700 pages after all it includes
funds for
new state imposed carbon reduction
requirements
1 billion dollars to the appalachian
regional commission
which is co-chaired by joe manchin's
wife millions for wildlife
crossing structures it refers to women
as socially disadvantaged individuals
and in one part of the bill stipulates
that gender identity
will be a protected class under federal
law
of course this is how it always goes
though right when one party has been
given
all the leverage they get cocky and they
go too far but in this case who's going
to stop them
white house senior adviser mike donald
sent out a positively giddy note to
democrats today
in part saying president biden continues
to propose and deliver plans that the
american people
across party lines agree are good for
the country
he's doing exactly what he said he'd do
when he ran for the job acting not as a
president of the red or blue states
but a president of the united states
well amidst an unprecedented crisis of
biden's own making
at the white house amidst the new
pessimism
and confusion about biden's handling of
the kova delta variant of the border
it's breaking down
his approval numbers last week hit a low
of 50 percent but now courtesy of the
romney group
republicans have given biden bragging
rights
they've given him a lifeline he'll not
only be able to claim a huge legislative
victory
and more significantly a glide path to
this gargantuan
3.5 trillion dollar reconciliation bill
legislation that can pass that a single
gop vote
and yet can transform huge sectors of
american society perhaps forever
the democrats justified the cost of the
infrastructure bill by claiming by the
way
it was fully paid for huh
well here's the wall street journal's
analysis that just came out tonight
west virginia democrat joe manchin and
his senate republican
friends are stressing that their deal is
fully paid for but read their lips
no new deficit spending read their bill
though it relies
on a great degree on savings and revenue
already baked into the fisk or the
treasury
and that's unlikely to happen now given
that we already loaded an unconscionable
burden of debt on our kids and our
grandkids
and given how fast our economy began to
recover from the pandemic that's good
news
a smart path would be for the romney
group right now
to reassess their support for this
infrastructural deal and it includes
mitch mcconnell by the way
go to the voters explain how the
democrats change the rules mid-game
and head into the midterms with a clear
message that america just needs to open
up for business fully without burdensome
mandates
no more accounting gimmicks gimmicks and
no more legislative games we're not
going to do any
of that otherwise we may be rebuilding
some bridges
but the country is going nowhere good
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it
anywhere else